film is an expensive and complicated
medium when storyteller suddenly
realized that their movie is heading for
an unsatisfying conclusion it can result
in some exhausting and expensive
behind-the-scenes headaches for everyone
involved thankfully those beloved movies
swapped out their Fe endings just in
time for the most part at the beginning
of Scott Pilgrim vs. the world the
eponymous hero is caught between two
women his two young for him girlfriend
the night's Chow and the mysterious
ramona flowers early on in the film he
cheats on knives with Ramona
and then breaks up with knives
altogether but his new relationship with
Ramona is far from smooth if we're gonna
date you may have to defeat my seven
evil exes if 70 more ex-boyfriends seven
evil exes yes how does the story end
well when Edgar Wright and Michael Baca
were writing the script for Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world they had a unique
problem it was based on a six-part comic
series by Bryan Lee O'Malley but only
five of the six books have been released
at the time there was no ending for them
to adapt the initial ending they penned
had Scott realizing that Ramona wasn't
right for him and so he and knives got
back together
the ending was shot and appears as a
bonus feature on the blu-ray instead
yeah but something about it didn't feel
right during filming in addition the
test audiences not liking it one of the
loudest voices against it was Alan Wong
the actor playing knives who didn't want
a character going back to a man who
cheated on her in the final ending
despite their problems Scott and Ramona
decide that they're going to try to make
it work and knives learns to stand on
her own bye and stuff
yeah
and stuff
don't get her this ended up matching the
resolution of the comic series the last
volume of which was released less than a
month before the film hit theaters rogue
one a Star Wars story was a project that
was constantly shifting around drawing
all stages of its production there was
an early version of the script where
protagonist jyn erso was a sergeant an
enlisted soldier in the Rebel Alliance
instead of a criminal who was pressured
into joining the rebellion in some
versions of the script she and casseon
actually survived the battle on scare
off' this incarnation of Jim was the one
that filmmakers thought they will be
going with when much of the merchandise
was created because of that some of the
packaging for the toys still refer to
Janus sergeant jyn erso
however there was another key change to
the ending that was made very late into
the filming process while looking over
the footage they had filmed for the
climax director Gareth Edwards and
editor J buzz Olsen realized that Darth
Vader
despite being introduced in an early
scene never really got a chance to do
anything cool in the third act
they decided he needed an action scene
of his own and so that now iconic Darth
Vader hallway fight scene was shot just
four months before the film was released
as a filmmaker Terry Gilliam is known
for two things making amazing surreal
movies and having terrible luck while
trying to make amazing surreal movies
the story of his 1985 film Brazil
showcases both of these traits Brazil
tells the story of Sam Lowry who lives
in a totalitarian futuristic bureaucracy
but dreams of being a winged hero who
fights monsters and rescues damsels
after a series of misadventures Sam is
captured by the authorities for
associating with criminal
revolutionaries in the original ending
he seemingly breaks out of captivity and
flees the city to an idyllic countryside
but then there is a sudden reveal that
he hasn't fled at all he is still in
prison merely dreaming of escape after
being lobotomized
The Criterion documentary the Battle of
Brazil tells the story of what happened
next
distributors felt that US audiences
would want a happier ending and I would
get calls from the editor occasionally
wanting my input you want my input yeah
but we're saving your film no you're
killing my film against Williams wishes
an editing team created an alternate
cuts that ended with some out to the
escaping for
going there revealed that it was just a
hallucination this was a version of
Brazil that was originally premiered in
the United States fortunately this is
not the end of the story
Gilliam unhappy with this results
started hosting private screenings of
his version of the film his cut started
getting positive critical attention
eventually winning the Los Angeles Film
Critics Award for Best Picture
this made the studio finally cave and
release the original version to American
audiences when Sean Harris was cast in
Mission Impossible rogue nation as the
villainous Solomon Lane he had only one
request without which he would not agree
to do the film he said quotes promised
me you'll kill him I don't want to be in
five of these movies writer director
Christopher McQuarrie agreed by the end
of the film protagonist Ethan Hunt would
kill Solomon Lane the problem late in
the process of filming McQuarrie made an
upsetting discovery in the wire reports
of the writer director admitted quote I
didn't have the events in the movie that
made me want Ethan to kill him in fact
McQuarrie felt it would be more
satisfying if Ethan tricked Elaine
defeating him without violence and
brought him into custody alive after
some pleading McQuarrie eventually got
Harris to agree to a script change in
the end Harris liked his character was
trapped there hasn't been five films yet
but Solomon Lane did indeed have to
return a Mission Impossible fallouts
pretty-in-pink tells the story of Andy
Walsh played by Molly Ringwald a high
schooler caught between two love
interests the preppy hunk Blaine and
ducky the boy next door
originally the plan was Fanti to learn
that people who are rich and attractive
like Blaine can sometimes be shallow and
people who don't look like much often
the real treasure that's of course
ducky were talking about however once
filming began Ringwald and McCarthy
ended up having an deniable chemistry
ducky meanwhile came off as a deeply
weird dude with strange fashion sense
odd mannerisms and an almost stalker
esque obsession with unday the film was
shot originally as written with Andy
ending up with ducky but audiences who
was shown early cuts of the film just
about lost their minds as director
Howard Deutsch put the girls in the test
screening didn't go for that they wanted
her to get the cue boy and that was
there so we had to reshoot the ending
the final version of the film did indeed
have Andy
with Blaine but the change happened so
late into the process that the
novelization of the film still has the
original ending this change never sat
well with writer John Hughes wanting
another chance to properly execute this
story he wrote some kind of wonderful
which has a very similar sets up to
pretty-in-pink but this time ends with a
lead choosing the Normie over the Hutt a
really embed damned world was zis
original ending which was actually
filmed was an enormous and expensive
action set piece with protagonist Jerry
Lane played by Brad Pitt fighting his
way through hundreds of zombies in
Moscow's Red Square
however when watching it back the
filmmakers felt that it just wasn't
working the story began with a strong
focus on Jerry's desire to reunite with
his family but it ended with a meeting
this bloodbath and their resolution to
his main goal in an interview with
Vanity Fair second unit director Simon
Crain said that the biggest problem was
that quotes it wasn't character driven
anymore writer Damon Lindelof was
brought on to take things back to the
drawing board and do something that had
never been done before on a film of this
scale write a completely new final 40
minutes to an already finished film in
the version that hit theaters the new
climax is confined to an abandoned
hospital the action is small with Jerry
as a frightened everyman rather than a
swaggering badass most importantly in
the end he's finally reunited with his
family even though Ridley Scott's Blade
Runner is considered a classic nowadays
it was not always a favorite of sci-fi
cinephiles when it premiered reviews
were lukewarm and some last minute
studio meddling may have been to blame
in Scotts initial cuts the storytelling
was gloomy and mysterious especially the
last shot of the film which showed our
protagonists on the run from the law
boarding an elevator to an uncertain
fate according to the making of
documentary on the edge of played runner
initial test screenings indicated that
this highly ambiguous plot did its job a
little too well because everyone who saw
it felt highly confused am i watching
here the studio pressured Scott's had
not only a voiceover narration to make
things clearer but also a new ending
that showed the hero's driving through
the sunny countryside indicating that
they'd found some semblance of happiness
the production was out of money but
Scott was suddenly in need of some
idyllic landscape footage he turned to
his friend Stanley Kubrick who happened
to have 17 hours of beautiful and news
to b-roll
that he originally shot for the opening
titles of the shining despite everyone's
best efforts the fix ended up pleasing
exactly nobody some still thought the
movie was confusing while others thought
the new voiceover and ending were too
corny
it wasn't until 1992 that Ridley Scott
released a version of the film more in
line with his initial vision and lovers
of confusing gloom finally got the flick
they've been dreaming of speaking of
Stanley Kubrick the notoriously intense
director is no stranger to switching
things up at the last possible minute
how old last minute are we talking
exactly well he changed the ending to
the shining a week after it came out the
initial ending of the film featured an
additional scene between the two now
famous final beats of Jack freezing to
death in the hedge maze and the closing
shot of that spooky group photo back in
the Overlook Vista version showed Wendy
and Danny recovering in a hospital and
talking to the police about what they
experienced this scene was actually
shown at the premiere and in the film's
initial limited run in Los Angeles and
New York then before the wider release
of the film Kubrick decided the scene
was superfluous and sent out assistance
to actually travel around to dozens of
theaters and physically cut out the
scene we editing the film reels that the
theaters have been showing the scene is
not currently available anywhere since
all copies of it were theoretically
destroyed only a few set photos still
exist but the evidence of how late this
change occurred can be seen in that two
characters from that scene a policeman
and the nurse still appear in the final
credits despite no longer being in the
movie so in summation the blade runner's
team took footage from The Shining to
create a new ending while The Shining
crew also crafted a new ending for the
horror film by pacing around the country
and taking razor blades to films
effectively becoming pardon the pun and
I can't believe I'm about to say this
blade runners oh I get it the classic
90s slacker comedy clerks tells the
story of the day in a life of a sad-sack
convenience store clerk Dante Hicks
even though the film garnered critical
acclaim jump-started the career of
director Kevin Smith and introduced a
well to Jay and Silent Bob the original
ending told a drastically different
story in his first public screening of
the independent feature film market
clerks ended with one last customer
entering the store as Dante was closing
up for the
he was an armed robber who without
warning or fanfare shot Dante dead
emptied the register and walked away
talk about a dead-end job in the making
of documentary snowball effects the
story of clerks Smith admits that he did
this because he didn't know how else to
close the film and because he was
copying the structure of Spike Lee's do
the right thing which also takes place
entirely in one day and ends in tragedy
Brian O'Halloran the actor who played
Dante hated this ending as did Smith's
mentor filmmaker John Pearson Pearson
suggested simply cutting that scene and
ending on the happy note that preceded
it that's exactly what Smith did and so
all the future screenings ended in a way
that better fit the tone of the rest of
the film and left the door open for a
sequel check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you